[Musique]
l'histoire que nous allons vous raconter
maintenant est celle de nombreuses ville
nouvelle bâtie rapidement occupé
immédiatement sans que les promoteurs
les urbanistes enfin les responsables
concernés n'est prévu les
infrastructures nécessaires à la vie
quotidienne
celles et ceux dont marisa d'où va vous
faire faire la connaissance n'invite
cependant pas le bout du monde mais
c'est un comble à paris
[Musique]
ici nous sommes dans le 15e
arrondissement de paris au bord du
périphérique et à proximité de lits port
3000 personnes habitent des logements
sociaux construits sur la plaine
vaugirard un quartier excentré qui
aurait pu trouver nouvelles animations
une vraie vie grâce aux espaces
disponibles et au complexe sportif
installé depuis plusieurs années et
pourtant ce coin de paris est devenu
aujourd'hui le bout du monde un ghetto
une île la zone c'est ainsi que les
habitants définissent leur quartier et
il est vrai que rien ne fonctionne
normalement pas de bureau de poste pas
d'autobus à proximité
pratiquement pas de commerces et une
insécurité permanente pour les parents
pour les enfants c'est aussi un vrai
casse tête
une école primaire a été construite et
malheureusement elle ne peut ouvrir
l'école n'existe pas encore qu'elle ne
peut pas ouvrir parce que la protection
civile ne déménage pas elle va peut-être
déménagé en juin mais ça fait cinq ans
que cette cité construite
ça fait cinq ans que les parents
attendent une école pour les autres
il ya quand même près de 3000 personnes
dans cette cité
aucune école primaire c'est quand même
un passage indispensable et
l'administration à l'heure actuelle
qu'est-ce qu'elle des vieilles à
plusieurs administrations et c'est ça le
problème il ya l'éducation nationale
dont il ya la ville de paris qui à la
protection civile qui dépend du
ministère de l'intérieur et donc toutes
ces administrations se battent entre
elles et finalement c'est ce qu'ils en
feront les frais ce sont nos enfants
[Musique]
pourquoi nous scolaire les enfants
prennent un car de ramassage le matin et
ce sont les ce sont les seuls petits
parisiens à le faire ça c'est une
originalité on a fait les frais aussi
alors les parents voient partir leurs
enfants à 8 heures le matin et ne les
revoit que le soir parce que même les
maires qui ne travaille pas ne peuvent
pas les avoir à l'heure du déjeuner et
star massage scolaire comme on en voit
dans les campagnes et on est dans paris
l'absence l'autobus est ressentie comme
un vrai drame
il ya un sentiment de gêne parce qu'on
n'a pas l'impression ni d'appartenir à
paris eni à issy les moulineaux
nous sommes une sorte d'exil eu alors
j'ai ce problème moi d'aller la semaine
dernière à la sécurité sociale où
j'étais convoqué eh bien il pleuvait
j'ai dû me rendre à pied la sécurité
sociale parce que c'est à balard
derrière bas la rue saint-charles et
nous n'avons qu'un moyen de transport y
aller alors je pense aux gens qu'ils
sont fatigués qu'ils doivent aller
toucher leurs indemnités les gens qui
doivent aller
les mères de familles qui doivent avec
leurs enfants se présentent et enfin
nous avons énormément de difficultés
durant plusieurs années il n'y avait
aucun commerce une pharmacie a été
ouverte récemment mais on ne sait si
elle pourra être maintenue car les
habitants font toujours leurs courses
dans d'autres quartiers
une pharmacie était absolument
nécessaire c'était bien une nécessité
seulement je me retrouve avec dix ans
six mille habitants dans un rayon très
courts et sans aucun autre service pour
la population
finalement c'est une petite ville sans
rien d'autre à côté si ce n'est un
dépannage alimentaire à côté et une
pharmacie
dans ces immeubles vivent de nombreux
retraités et les femmes seules
depuis des mois ils réclament la
création d'une antenne de commissariats
ou pour le moins d'un poste d'îlotiers
les déprédations sont fréquentes et les
agressions se multiplient alors pour les
gens du troisième âge et pour bien des
femmes
la vie est devenu différent d après midi
on se retrouve
mais le soir chacun s'enferme car on
n'ose plus sortir pour qu'un des
premiers problème le plus important ce
serait un service de sécurité parce que
les agressions qui les a depuis un bon
moment
vraiment ce serait nécessaire
[Musique]
avant d'habiter dans la plaine de
vaugirard vous étiez vous aurions
dernière mais qu'est ce que c'est que
vous amenez alors invité ces mêmes états
cas dans une petite pièce il avait
remporté par tout agent plafond s'est
écroulé
viva katherine ans était plus possible
et enfin vous avez trouvé bon hlm et ça
fait combien de temps ça bah ça fera
quatre mandats premier masque j'habite
ici
ausy plaisir et pourquoi vous y prêtez
plus bas se passer pas mal de trucs et
puis ça devient de plus en plus voyants
ça devient de plus en plus voyez vous
mais ce qui vous est arrivé des choses à
vous personnellement oui mais quand on
dit ça c'est vous êtes arrivé quoi bon
bah
en plusieurs reprises
jus de la ville en pleine nuit des coups
dans ma porte en citer pas moi c'est une
troisième fois le palier quand est pris
aussi c'étaient des coûts chez eux
une autre femme penny a fait appel à
plus parce que on s'en est pris à mes
volets
on dit comme ça je trouve que ça
paysager veille en art
et vous avez surtout peur à quel moment
dans la journée ainsi à plat ou le soir
surtout les soirs l'histoire
[Musique]
vous sentez quand même non non non je
sais pas sortir le soir jean son avance
certaine gêne c'est un autre problème
pour les habitants de la plaine gojira
la proximité de l'héliport de paris
les hélicoptères ne respectent pas
toujours les couloirs de circulation et
les immeubles sont survolés dans un
bruit infernal
mieux il serait question d'installer ici
des ateliers de réparation qui servirait
pour les travaux et les essais de toutes
les bases du pays
les associations de locataires et
certaines municipalités ont déjà
manifesté leur mécontentement depuis
quelques temps ce problème est devenu
effectivement très préoccupant à un
double titre
premièrement les hélicoptères ne
respecte pas la procédure d' approche au
lieu de suivre la scène et de tourner
autour de la tour edf
il traverse directement survol des
groupes scolaires et ainsi créer une
pollution extrêmement désagréable pour
nos enfants
deuxièmement cela n'est rien à côté du
risque déjà annoncé du transfert de
l'atelier national de réparation des
hélicoptères sur l'héliport d'issy
moulineaux qui dit réparation dix essais
dits nuisances du bruit considérable et
compte tenu de l'expérience précédente
nous tenons absolument pas à ce que
cette opération se réalise je sais
d'ailleurs que le maire de paris mon
collègue intervient en ce sens et il y à
une sorte de consensus des habitants
d'ici moulineaux et de paris pour
protester à l'avance contre cette mesure
qui ne contribuera pas la qualité de m
pourquoi un atelier décès et de
réparation dans une zone aussi urbanisé
la raison peut paraître surprenante
la plupart des sociétés qui travaillent
à la fabrication ou à la
commercialisation des hélicoptères sont
implantés sur l'héliport de paris
et elles ne veulent pas elles ne
tiennent pas à déménager rapatrier les
hélicoptères de l'île de marseille pour
les faire réparer à bari je voudrais
être sûr que cela est tout à fait
rentable
est-ce que d'autre part c'est aux
habitants d'un quartier d'une portion du
territoire ne supporter tous les risques
de pollution
pour l'ensemble de la france je crois
qu'il y à répartition à l'origine
excellent si votre main pour le
ministère de l'intérieur
cette situation est passagère et des
modifications vont être apportées très
prochainement avec le transfert de la
base
il est vrai que actuellement les
couloirs de circulation ne sont pas
respectées car les services de la
navigation aérienne ont défini un conte
d'envol sorte d'entonnoir qui s'élève de
façon à ce que hélicoptère passe le plus
loin possible des habitations
mais nous sommes notre emplacement
actuel est situé en dehors de ce cône
donc à l'heure actuelle compagne
respecter mais là nous retrouvons le
problème du transfert de la base et dès
lundi prochain
nos mouvements d'hélicoptères comme tous
ceux de l'aéroport s'intégreront dans le
mouvement général de l'aéroport et les
procédures navigation aérienne seront
respectés cette histoire de la plaine
vaugirard c'est aussi celle de
nombreuses villes nouvelles des cités
dortoirs construite depuis une vingtaine
d'années ont bâti en parant au plus
pressé et en oubliant l'indispensable
c'est à dire les infrastructures les
équipements nécessaires à toute vie
collective
aujourd'hui pour que ici ça fonctionne
et que les gens sont satisfaits que ce
qu'il faudrait il faut absolument que il
une notion de vie de ceux de cette
petite ville qu'elle a plein de
vaugirard qui que l'on puisse faciliter
les rapports humains et ceci ne pourra
avoir lieu que s'il ya des commerces que
s'il y a une poste s'il est un
commissariat de police
enfin tous les éléments nécessaires à la
vie d'une cité
croient voir des quartiers disparus des
banlieues rasé des villes dites
nouvelles
pourquoi pas toute vie et mouvement les
transformations
mais faut-il réaliser ses projets sur le
dos et au détriment d'une population
un reportage de la télévision a ceci de
bon qu'il fait souvent accélérer les
choses ainsi depuis que maurice arnoux
est allé filmer la plaine gojira les
hélicoptères de la base de paris ont
effectivement quitté leur ancienne base
année part que les habitants de la
plaine attendait depuis longtemps mais
les hélicoptères continuent d'aller se
ravitailler en kérosène à la plaine de
vaugirard le ballet n'est donc pas
complètement terminée malgré les
promesses faites
[Musique]